want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn
what you need to know about making money
enjoy
i am a nice guy until somebody starts
complaining to me
about how hard they have it
and i have to tell you nothing pisses me
off
more than people that complain
or people that have this feeling
the life owes them something
and i kind of really learned that from
my dad i mean my dad was this really
proud guy
and he would say that he was a political
prisoner
he wasn't he was just a young guy who
liked to drink
and he would go to a bar in a communist
country
drink a little too much and say screw
communism
and they'd throw him in jail and
you know the the normal person would
would kind of make that connection
oh if i stand up in a bar and say screw
communism and go to jail this isn't a
good thing
my dad took it the other way he was like
i'll show them
and so the next time he stood up he said
even worse things about communism
fundamentally he was a really proud guy
and he hated
the idea of building
equity or building capital and having to
share it
with somebody who wasn't working as hard
as he was you know the thing i learned
from my dad is he was okay with having
nothing
he was okay with working really hard he
was okay with getting
knocked down in life but he wasn't okay
if he created something was successful
that
somebody would take it away from him and
that's what he hated about communism
and what i took out of all that is you
know when we came to canada just to get
a job he had to work in a factory and he
swept
floors and and the whole nine yards and
i'll never forget one time
because it was really hard for me i grew
up in this little village when my
grandmother raised me
and i always liked to talk and so i
didn't have to work hard on the farm and
there was pigs and donkeys it was
you know it was pretty good as a small
kid and then i come to
north america and i get thrown into a
classroom i don't speak the language i
look funny
we're very poor i never realized we were
poor until i got here
i come home one day and i'm crying
because the kids beat me up
and they were mean to me and i'm like oh
my gosh
nobody loves me why i don't have any
friends
my life sucks and i'm sitting there
complaining to my mom and my dad walks
through the door
and he's kind of listening and he had
literally just walked
two miles from the bus stop after having
worked two
shifts in the factory and he's listening
to this
when i'm done complaining he looks at me
and he says uh
you know life doesn't owe you anything
never complain all you owed is an
opportunity
and in this country you have an
opportunity and then he went to sleep
so he could wake up the next day and
work two more shifts
right it's pretty amazing
so you know when you have when you have
that as your compass it's really hard
to complain there are days like
everybody in this room there are days
where i see
overbearing difficulty there are days
where i see
more no then i see yes there are days
where i see
harder things than see opportunities but
it doesn't last
that long it's not about eliminating
that stuff out of your life it's working
through it
and and keeping going we've all been
told that
money doesn't grow on trees and what
that is
is we feel that money is scarce or in
fact we live in a fear that it's gonna
run out
are going to vanish and we know that
money doesn't vanish money is not
going away there's the same amount of
money if not more
around the world than there's ever been
it's not getting smaller
think about that like really think what
i just said money is not shrinking
right in fact this year in america alone
and i've said the stats a lot of you
have heard this but
because it boggles my mind that there's
1700
new millionaires being created every day
in america
think about that seventeen hundred new
millionaires
every single day in america what happens
is when we think about money is scarce
and it doesn't go on trees and we have
this
feeling that it's getting shrinking and
it's going away what we ask ourselves
is this how do i protect myself
how do i save this money how do i make
sure no one takes what i have
[Music]
and that mindset keeps you on the
sidelines
i want you to say what about asking
yourself a different question because
here's the thing
if money doesn't disappear
if we know it's the same amount or more
can we agree on that if it's not
disappearing
then all it is is money is moving from
one group of people
to another group of people same amount
of money if they're still
let's say there's a hundred dollars and
you're moving it around amongst a bunch
of people it's just
who's getting the chunk of it there's
still a hundred dollars the same sum
total is there it's just moving
differently
so the question you should be asking
yourself is now how do i hold on to what
i have how do i make sure i don't lose
any of this how do i make sure you know
i keep the lights off at night
i'm not saying you shouldn't be
conservative what i'm saying is instead
of having that mindset what we should be
saying is
how do i become the person and this is
one
write this down i hope you i hope you're
paying attention here today guys i hope
you're
not playing with social media looking
around trying to focus on this because
the question should be
how do i become the person
where the money is moving to rather than
away from
right just the same little same thought
process just a different
shift instead of instead of thinking
money is scarce and it's going away you
know there's 1700 new millionaires a day
in america alone being created
right now money's not getting scarce
it's just those people money is flowing
to them
and somebody else who's standing there
trying to protect the little and protect
themselves
and and being thinking a scarce mindset
their money
is slowly going away now i am surely
not going to be an advocate or say
that you shouldn't be conservative that
you shouldn't save money that you
shouldn't be smart with your money
of course you should but here's what i
know
in the evolution of my life of going
from that kid living in a bathroom with
my dad and not having money and all
those things and i'm not saying that to
give you my
my my pitch or my story but when i look
back at when i tried to save and be
conservative because i listened to
you know maybe grandparents that went
through the depression or listened to
people that you know was like you're
crazy what i realize is
when you change your mindset on money
when you gain the capabilities
and when you take action it is
in my opinion you can disagree with me
in my opinion
money is easier to flow to you and make
it than it is to save it i even look at
that in my business i was like hey let's
tighten up on expenses and i'll look
through all these things like okay if we
tighten up all those because we're such
a big company now
we could save this much but if we if i
write a new book if i start a new
campaign if i do some more real estate
deals i can bring in this much with a
little
with the same amount of effort like save
this much or just make this much how the
hell with it
keep everybody there keep the lights on
i'm going to go make it over here
now i might be in extreme but i'd like
to give you a little bit of that
that if we stand on the sidelines
envying those making more
being not jealous but like desiring what
other people have but we're afraid
because we want to hold on to what we
have and be afraid to take action
a lot of times those opportunities pass
us by
money when is money worth something this
money
can only bring me peace of mind right
now i got my money in my bag in case
something happens
this money does not become valuable
though until i pull it out of the bag oh
here's some 50s and 20s plugged in there
how did this time what's that money that
those people gave you on stage
yeah yeah that's right so so this money
is only valuable when
okay first lesson i want to share with
you money only becomes valuable
when it is used money is not valuable in
the bank
money is not valuable sitting waiting
for your retirement it might give you
some peace of mind some
some idea that you're going to be fined
and you're going to be
protected you know when you stop working
and that you're going to be able to
retire and live happily ever after
because you have money sitting on a 401k
or a retirement account or a
ira or you've got a bunch of money
sitting in a savings account but the
truth is
you're you can't produce money when it
sits in the bank
money is only valuable only valuable
when it's used okay
a millionaire gets a little bit of money
and the first thing they want to do is
protect their money
god makes 100 grand first time in his
life he wants to protect his hunter he
makes five thousand first time he wants
to protect
he goes into protection rather than
going out and getting more money this is
why people become
complacent this is why so many people go
out today and just ask people
hey you making enough money i guarantee
you
sixty to seventy percent of the people
you ask ask ten people
six to seven of them are gonna say no
i'm good they can barely make ends meet
no i'm good man you wanna make more
money uh you know money's not everything
money won't make me happy
you know i'm fine they're making sense
they're complacent with what they have
why
because they're trying to protect it
rather than they get go get more of it
and by the way they think that the money
that they now have
is theirs see poor people
are always very opinionated they always
want to tell the world about the
opinions
about politics about sports about the
society
about the government about every single
thing that's around them
versus being humble willing to learn
rich people we're always learning we're
asking questions
we are listening we are reading books
continuous learning versus
saying that i've got an opinion about
everything
you know why they're always an opinion
poor people because the only way to get
a little bit of
attention no different i can see people
they're watching my video watching my
sales video closing video
and i just look at that and i laugh and
they comment oh dan
you shouldn't close this way you should
close that way just say this
when was the last time you closed
something
show me when's the last time you closed
something for 500
1 000 2 000 5 000
10 000 a hundred thousand dollars what
the [ __ ] have you done
so your opinion doesn't count remember
your income can only grow to the extent
that you do your wealth
can only grow as fast as you do
the beauty of the world today is that
you know like if when i went to work for
standard oil of california
i got paid by the month
and if i was a pilot flying for the
airlines i got paid by the month
and when i worked on straight
commissions with xerox i got
you know basically commissions
but i realized from my rich dad talking
to me
if i understood financially i could make
money 24
7 without working that was a difference
so what you'll be learning about
today is how we make money 24
7 without working to me that makes a lot
more sense
than working hard all the time the the
basics of financial education begins
with this with literacy
is it begins with an income statement
and a balance sheet this is the
fundamental
if you are going to be
wealthy
if you look over here after mission
it's cash flow this this is basically
accounting
cfo's uh auditing departments
so as a young boy that's what my rich
dad started me on this he says
if you can manage this you'll always be
a rich man no matter what happens to you
so
this here's income expense asset
liability
where people get messed up is they call
their house an
asset and he says that's the problem
they call their car and ask it
but gap general account generally
accepted accounting principles
i can actually count this suit as an
asset
and that's what that's what my rich dad
said that's where people get messed up
see so this this form is called an
income statement in america this is
called a balance sheet there's a third
form
it's called a statement of
cash flow okay so when you look at this
here
this here is the real game board from
the from my cash flow game
this is income this income statement
balance sheet statement of cash flow
okay so it's the game is teaching you as
a kids version
intermediate version advanced version is
teaching you while you're having fun
so the mis so very simply my rich dad
said
assets put money in your pocket so this
is the cash flow pattern of an asset it
goes from
the asset it could be my
a house i rent out okay boom
so assets put money in your pocket
whether you work or not
so what's the difference in asset assets
what put money in your pocket
whether you work or not one more time
assets what
put money in your pocket whether you
work or not
now i asked somebody on singapore and i
said
can you can you name an asset you have
this little chinese woman raised her
hand she says
oh yes yes yes my husband my husband
i was hot
i said i'm talking about inanimate
objects she says oh he doesn't do
anything anyway you know
and so a liability takes money from your
pocket
let's definitely liability takes money
from your pocket so the reason people
are afraid of losing their job is
because
they have liability to think are assets
so they have to keep going to work
stop looking for employment
why don't you position yourself
differently and look for deployment
to be employed means that somebody else
is benefiting from your energy
to deploy me to deploy yourself means
that you are
using your own energy to be productive
so
instead of waiting for someone to give
you a job create your own work
that's why i tell people that's
different between your work and your job
your job is what they train you to do
your work is what you were born to do
your job is your skill which they can
fire you from the same time
but your work is your gift no one can
take that from you
your job is where you get compensation
for
activity your work is where you get
fulfillment
because you love it so much your job you
can retire from
your work you can never retire from work
because your work is you
so when a person discovers their work
they no longer need a job
because their work makes them productive
so the young people in this country
who are full of talents full of gifts
and
i want to say this too every problem in
life is a business
all businesses are simply someone
solving a problem
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35 is
not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you if you had to define
the american dream what would you say it
is that
when you think that there's all the
opportunity you want
and you don't know any better you go
after it
in my generation it was a pleasure work
whether it was at the variety boys club
at seven years old making flower pots
going on selling them or
christmas cards at nine or uh going on
the streets at
11 years old delivering morning
newspapers
for us it was fun to work now what do we
do with the money we gave to my mom so
we have a better way of life
we got into high school my brother and i
saved a little bit of it
for our car which happened to be a
junker but we rebuilt it in auto shop
but because we for us it was a pleasure
to work you know just because wow we got
a job it was so cool
the two big things is how do you get uh
your
alignment of your lower level you with
your upper level u how do you get um
past your ego and your blind spot we
know what the ego barrier is like i got
to be right
or whatever it is or i'm not good at
this the blind spot barrier
is the realization that people actually
see things different
they see different things like somebody
will see the big picture
somebody will see the detail they'll
focus on different things almost like a
color spectrum type of thing
and if you realize that you will see a
part of that spectrum and other people
will see the other part of the spectrum
and so that you really need to when you
go above yourself you really need to
orchestrate
all those ways of seeing because you are
not
just one of those people that's got to
do it yourself
your way of being the the success is to
go above it and be the
orchestrator and know what you're good
at and what you're not good at
so it's almost like if you want your
life to be successful
you will not let yourself do certain
things
because you're just no good at them once
you get that picture down
then you can find the past wherever the
paths are you're open-minded
because you now you've given up your ego
barrier and your
blind spot barrier when we do and i do a
fair amount of sales training on my own
team here but
i often talk about we don't close here
so we don't close a sale we open a
relationship
the way we lead the sales process is the
whole time
we're having a conversation with you to
give you a sense of why you would
benefit by having a relationship
with us this has nothing to do with
whether or not you buy from us this is
just like
we want to have a relationship with you
and we have that relationship by
offering these
products which we believe suit this need
of yours and by the way it's connected
to the things you find important
if these are the things you find
important because we do then we should
sustain this relationship for a period
of time and we do that by having you
sign this contract
so we really you know and i've taken a
lot of time to i've spent a lot of time
with my sales team going
don't close a sale people should never
feel like you've closed anything
they should rather feel like they've
become part of something part of a
family part of a movement
part of something that matters something
that's going to make a difference right
especially today's world with
millennials you know who don't buy
stuff based on on value they buy stuff
based on values
so what you really want to make sure is
that you open the sale
i think public speaking taught me that
kind of instinctively because
in public speaking what you're doing is
you're communicating a very complex set
of ideas
as simply as possible and you're doing
it in the hope that people are
that it's going to inspire action so you
know when martin luther king said i have
a dream that one day the sons of former
slaves and the sons of former slave
owners
will be able to break bread on the table
of brotherhood the first thing he did is
he used imagery because
the minute the mind can see it then then
you're closer to doing it right
but the second thing he does is says i
have a dream
towards the end of the speech if you
listen to it he says we need a messaging
to the united states that says that you
guys
have issued us this check for the
promises you've made but this check has
returned saying no money in the bank
account
so he says even though i have this dream
if the
system of the situation doesn't allow
this dream to be actualized it's not
going to be actualized and um
and that works that's really really an
effective way of doing it so i would say
to anybody who's in
a sales process particularly people who
are entrepreneurs if you're an
entrepreneur you're selling every day
is you don't close a sale you open a
relationship and you open a relationship
in the same way you would when you want
to date someone by going
i like you i think we have a bit of
chemistry i think this thing could go
somewhere
but i think so what do you say about a
date then at the end of the first day to
go what do you say about the second one
right that's kind of in our firm that's
kind of how we think about building
relationships with clients it's just
do you see the world in this way we see
the world in this way
what do you say we go on a date let's
try something together
um and that opening of relationships is
far more sustainable because
by the way just one final thing every
time you close a sale notice what you
have to do is you have to make a hard
promise
you never have to you never close a sale
without making a hard promise
so before you close the sale you go
through the promising state where you go
i promise my product or my business is
going to do
one two three four five when you open a
relationship you don't really
make a promise you make a commitment you
kind of go
i commit that i'm gonna be available
that i'm gonna do the best i can
that i'm gonna make sure that i'm gonna
do the best i can to make sure that we
succeed
but a commitment is different because
the promise is final and commitment
allows for latitude
so in a commitment where you fail you
can be honest and go
i thought it would but it didn't work or
there's a problem here it's a mechanical
issue
and because you've opened a relationship
people are a lot more forgiving
than if you made very hard promises
trying to close a sale
and now this thing doesn't do what you
said it would do six months in everybody
works hard
and everybody has their own dreams there
is
there was a time where i used to spend a
lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things are
nice i like them
but this is what i learned when you can
surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to earth to claim
for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning
should have been in church but i
wouldn't
i was reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book
i got out of bed in my pajamas put on my
galoshes
and went to the store to get the copy of
the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple
i took the books to to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear that somebody's
gonna do a movie about the color purple
but i don't know anybody in the movie
business by this time i was on am
chicago
i don't know anybody i start praying to
god god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as as divine law would have it quincy
jones
comes to chicago and he is
in chicago for one half of a day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room he was coming
out of the shower and the television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago quincy jones
tells ruben cannon the casting agent i
think i found
sophia so i get a call from ruben cannon
who says i'm calling about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and i
say i have not been praying for moon
song
[Applause]
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know all the words by
heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie
oh that i'm thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because
the fat has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i i also was trying to make peace
with it i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track at
the fat farm
it starts to rain y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my
life i start praying running around the
track
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
[Applause]
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord i'll come
and let it go then you get up and you go
well i think i still got a little bit of
it
i did help me let it go but i am not
going to be able to see the other
actress
in my part i won't be able to see it i
won't be able to see color purple
just can't never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came from
i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender
all i sang and i cried i sang and i
cried and i prayed some more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
oh to thee
my blessed savior
i surrender all
and i tell you in my greatest
testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman comes
running
out of the cafeteria
screaming oh free
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
no problem do i have
[Applause]
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
[Applause]
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired i would like
to tell you of
two women uh that
each sold the business to berkshire
hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was
everything they had in the world and one
of them
was a woman who landed in seattle
in 1917 couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck the tag
said fort dodge iowa
the red cross daughter of fort dodge
where she was reunited with her
husband who had come to the country a
couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy she couldn't pick
up the language she couldn't learn a
word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha so they came to omaha
in 1919 and
there she found a small colony of
russian jews so she started feeling more
at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
frances
and she would teach her mother the words
she'd learned in school
that day and this woman rose brumpkin
spent 20 years saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father fifty dollars at a
time she sold used clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she saved 2500
she went to chicago and she bought
what she could have furniture her dream
had always been to open
a furniture store and this woman would
who had never gone to school one day in
her life
with 2 500 but with the same spirit that
the people
in this room had about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business which she
sold to me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin lived
while she she worked for me until she
was 103.
and then i said then she retired and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all of berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b with her twenty five hundred
dollars
one further fact about her she could not
read or write and she went into a
furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she
brought a determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers she worked at
very low gross margins but she built
this incredible business
the challenge of a problem or the
importance uh isn't that
related how likely you are to achieve it
and and in fact even when you go after a
more ambitious goal even if you fail to
achieve that one
uh all the side effects that come along
the way uh can be that much more
uh rewarding and significant in their
own right
and so you know i feel lucky that i fell
into
doing something that i feel really
matters you know getting people
information around the world about
anything
i i wish there was a way to convey that
too uh
you know to the world at large obviously
all of you uh already have this religion
uh but uh it's uh very rewarding when
you work on something you think is gonna
make a big difference and
yeah it's a little bit harder but i
think i think the
passion that one might bring with it
brings
so much more energy to that that you're
more likely to succeed
the real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation
is high then you don't need to worry
about protecting
vip because other companies will be
copying something
that you did years ago and that's fine
you know just
make sure your rate of innovation is
fast
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
um and i do i do say this to my teams
like
uh quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
what i say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
um 100 improvement in something and that
took 100 years
or one year that's radically different
so um it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that matters and is the rate of
innovation
um is that accelerating or decelerating
um and a weird thing happens when
companies get big is that
most companies or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh it's not there for innovation
um it's not enough to
use words to encourage innovation the
incentive structure must
be aligned with that that's fundamental
i'm not
smarter than anybody else but i can
outwork you
and my key to success for
you or for anybody else's make sure
you're the first one in there every day
and the last one to leave
don't ever take a lunch break or go to
the bathroom you keep working
you never know when that opportunity is
going to come along and at solomon
brothers
the managing partner of the company bill
solomon was the
second person in i was the only other
one in the big trading room
so if he had needed to borrow a match in
those days people smoked cigars
and if he wanted to ask something about
a newspaper or a stock
he came over and so we became buddies i
would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company
on a first name basis if it wasn't for
the fact that the two of us are there
billy i'm getting coffee would you like
some
and i can bring you that and at the end
of the day the number two guy
john good friend he was the last one to
leave except for me and we'd share a cab
going uptown or
take the subway train going uptown
together and you know
every opportunity ever had it was i
think a lot a lot of them was because i
was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can you can't control your luck but
the harder you work the luckier you get
you can't control
that you're the smartest guy they'll
always be somebody smarter
but if you're there then you absorb
things you put things together in a ways
that if you didn't have all that
experience
it's like skiing i've said reading a
book on skiing
doesn't teach you how to ski you got to
go and you got to
ski and get lots of miles under your
skis
and incidentally if you don't fall
you're not skiing hard enough and you're
not learning anything so
if your career has ups and downs i got
fired didn't turn out so bad
but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you've got to say be smart
to say hey i tried it
don't let your ego get in the way i
can't keep doing this i've got to earn a
living
but you know a year from now i'm going
to come up with a better idea and then
i'll go back and do it again
you have to have a plan in your life for
what's going to happen to you when you
hit your 60s and 70s and 80s and maybe
by then your 90s because people are
living longer all the time
how do you get a nest egg together well
the average salary in america is around
58
000 and so i'm going to give it to you
in a nutshell
you have to start saving in your early
years in your 20s
100 bucks a week minimum minimum
but it's not just the saving aspect
you've got to invest that money
so you have to take that hundred dollars
out of whatever your activity is or
you're going to start a side hustle
maybe you're going to be a photographer
maybe you're going to be a writer maybe
you're going to do something else
a separate job where you can make at
least you know 100 bucks a week
after tax and you're going to invest it
you're not going to
save it you're going to invest it
saving is what you have in cash
investing is what you put into the
market
now the market is a volatile thing is
the first question you know
made reference to and when you invest in
the stock market
what matters is diversification you
don't know which stocks are going to go
up and down or when
you don't know which sectors of the
economy are going to outperform the
others you have no idea
but if you look over a long period of
time what you see
is a market a stock market that returns
around six to eight percent a year
and if you start to put aside a hundred
bucks a week in your early years
you're going to end up with you know if
the markets do what they did for the
last hundred plus years
you'd end up with about a million and a
half dollars when you're 65.
that is really important what should i
be
you know going all in on should as you
know millennials that are starting
businesses like many people in our
community
uh they're you know going all in on
their business and you know they're
sacrificing profit for growth
you know so yeah they don't have that
much spare change what what's your
advice there what are your thoughts
i'm really glad you asked me that
question because every entrepreneur i
meet i have this conversation with
one-on-one people that are my friends
um and i do it in my business seminars
too when i show people i do business
boot camps and i
i spend five days showing how to grow
their business 100 plus and then i take
a half a day and show them what to do
to have a second business here's what
i'd say to you if you're a founder out
there if you're
somebody starting an organization the
amount of money that you
get whatever cash you have if it's a
growing business
will always be eaten up by the
organization so a friend of mine ken
blanchard who wrote the one minute
manager books you may have read years
ago
i met him 30 years ago and i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game so
he thought i was god
and i don't play golf i just know what
to do here and here with somebody
and so afterwards he goes i want to do
something for you i said looks like
you're not doing anything
about two months later calls me up says
i want to lunch with you i want to give
you a gift
he said i want to share with you the
best financial advice that changed my
life
so what is it he said this very wealthy
friend of mine saw i was writing a book
and he saw i was growing my business and
he said i want to tell you something
a business he said what i told you
earlier we'll take whatever cash is
there because a growing business
there's always needs he said you have to
draw a line in the sand and he said your
book should be the first line in the
sand you should put none of that money
in your company
the clients that like the book will
become clients of the company
and you shouldn't take that money you
should put an investment account that
you don't touch
and it continues to compound to create
financial freedom
he said tony i took his advice and then
i went through three different stages
where we almost went bankrupt in the
business
because i had so much cash and money i
wasn't stressed
so i was they'll keep my head straight
and run my business better because if
you think about it
i did that too i did my first books now
i give away all the profits in my books
my first books and my first infomercials
yes and i work
you know 275 days a year on the road i
never earned as much as i did by
compounding because
compounding changes the game so what you
have to do if you're a business owner
you have to get yourself where you say
i'm going to put a tax on my business
not the government tax my tax my future
self is going to be free forever
because look in business 96
of businesses don't make it in 10 years
i'm sure all of yours will
but even the four percent that make it
aren't necessarily profitable
so and the reason is because government
can change the rules
right taxes can shift radically affected
clients shift their preferences
technology new competition so i tell
everybody i believe you'll make your
business succeed but everybody should
have a business on the side with no
employees
no moving parts 20 minutes 15 minutes 30
minutes a year to rebalance it
so that if anything happens here you're
still strong and you can make this
stronger
or if this goes well and this goes well
as well you have twice as much money and
you're there
but you got to understand what this
compounding does right this compounding
you don't need a lot of money to get
really really wealthy
you know the example of one of the
examples i put in the book here was
the example of a man who talks to his
son he's 18 years old
and the man understands finance and
understands the power of compounding so
he says to his son
you got your first job you're 18. i'm
going to require
that you take 300 every month 150 bucks
a paycheck
and we're going to automate it to the
separate account and it sounds like i
can't do that he goes
let me tell you why you want to do it
it'll be up to you if you promise to do
that you really do it you automate it so
you don't see it
and you do that for eight years you'll
never have to invest again and you'll be
financially set for life
this thing goes come on dad eight years
three dollars a month what is that if he
does the math he goes that's 28 000
you know over here's 28 800 28
800 how's that going to do anything
especially if i don't have any more
money after 27 years old
he goes let me show you son the market's
gone up 10
over 30 years let's apply a lower number
let's do eight percent be conservative
let me show you what the numbers are
when they compound you know how much he
has when he retires 1.8 million dollars
and all he put in was 28 800. as a kid
you know when i was 25 years old and i
was you know making all this money on
wall street i thought that
business was about making money and it's
really not business is about
monetizing value in other words you have
a product an
idea a service that has values it helps
people it resolves their pain
it you know helps people live better
lives more empowered lives so they have
something of value
the business is set up around that idea
to monetize
that value how do you reach people in an
effective way through proper marketing
campaigns
how do you convince them what influence
them or persuade them to
say yes i'm going to buy it and give it
a shot because it makes sense to me and
get people sold to buy your product
right so this idea of how am i going to
manufacture my product in a way that
it's cheap enough so that i can
make my margin and still have the value
exchange so
business is about monetizing value so
what i want you to focus on as you sell
we're gonna
get off this sort of the the the ethical
stuff in a second we'll go into the
actual sales stuff but just
remember this make sure that you're
focusing on the value exchange
the equation i try to run in my mind
today is my own gut check is that if i
charge someone a dollar for something i
try to give them at least five or ten
dollars in value
i want every person that i sell
something to that buys my programs or my
product whatever it might be
i want to say wow that's a lot more
value
than i thought i was getting and if for
some reason that
it turns out that they don't like a
product i have or i want to refund their
money
like that i don't want any unhappy
people in this world i want people to
spread the message because i know that's
good business that's how i make money
and it's also right it also feels good
it's good karma and
it's all part of me sort of living an
entire life where i succeed but all
those around me succeed as well
in the future peop you will not make
money but make money by the service you
offer
you know how how good service you you do
it's going to be
how efficient you are and
alibaba we have we are company right now
have um
20 that's not including the financial
uh group we have 25 units
25 different uh business units maybe in
the future
we might have 50 i don't know right we
have that many
uh units and we are almost in everywhere
we control our head counts by efficiency
we have
we only have our two 24 24
000 people i tell you a story last
the thing i feel proud of the two years
ago we we started to have a
budgeting meeting and i asked my team
well year 2012 if we want to double all
the numbers we have
how many people we need and people say
seven thousand eight hundred new people
i said no no no check it again
and then they say six hundred thousand
eight hundred people as you know
and they might my people ask me how many
you want
i said 200. no impossible 200.
my answer is that for years we discussed
we should hire more people for future
i've heard this for 10 years now let's
let's let's just to do the efficient
thing
and i told all the management if we
have net income net you know had come
over
200 even one people
we should have no bonus for whole year
for year 2012.
and then we start the start the plan
year 2012 we net lose
1 000 people all the number doubled
and i say if we want to create more jobs
for the others
let's keep our head accounts make sure
because
right now we have over 500 million
registered users
on taobao no matter how many people we
hire ourselves
we cannot be always not enough people
so we can focus on technology
focusing on making sure the platform is
efficiency focusing
everybody makes the difference in the
platform that would make the difference
so your question is you know did i kind
of anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years
at amazon and the answer is god no so
you know amazon started as a very small
company
it was me and a few other people i was
driving
all the packages to the post office
myself in my 1987
chevy blazer and
when i raised money for amazon i had to
raise a million dollars
which i raised from 22 different
investors 50
000 each they got 20 of the company
for uh for the million dollars
and um it was
a 40 people told me no so i had to take
60 meetings
to get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet
and i had to walk through that and this
was 1994
early 95 and so did i anticipate
you know fast forward to today and and
the current version of it
no it has been one foot in front of the
other
and i think that that is true for most
businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively
it's step by step
you figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what
what else you can do what customers want
my father-in-law once gave me this
advice
he was the first person i met that had
really been successful
and he said what you want to do is
know more about any situation than
anyone else
in the world and i actually remember
what i said to him i said
yeah my boss doesn't really think like
that
i have since apologized to my
father-in-law for giving me such an
amazing piece of information and me
doing nothing with it for like six years
but once i understood that the only path
to excellence
is to truly become an expert the only
path to excellence is to actually get
good at something
these days in a hyper-connected world
where within minutes of an interaction
with you
your product whatever someone can have a
global audience and tell people what
they think
that product better be awesome but the
great news is
the world's been democratized now you no
longer have to have
150 million dollar ad budget in order to
cut through the clutter
in our first eight months we were
profitable at month six
in our first eight months we didn't
invest more than ten thousand dollars
because we had a product that actually
delivered value
our marketing message delivered value
and if you focus on that if you focus on
making something that's
better than what other people are doing
now you really can cut through the noise
very very quickly and you gotta grind
baby grind
that was me for almost two years
people see where the company's gotten
they see me
up giving speeches but what they don't
see is that in the middle of the night
my hands used to wake me up cramping
closed
because all day i was making protein
bars and in the very beginning
we were running the technology company
during the day and then going and making
protein bars by hand at night with
rolling pins and handheld blades
that we cut the bars and then wrapped
them three at a time we wrapped them
three at a time
we would make 1200 bars i think nine of
us made 1200 bars over a
six or seven hour period now in a day we
make 1.5 million
but that's where it starts it starts
with the willingness
to persist long after it's boring
it starts with the ability to focus on
your end customer
long after you're exhausted it starts
with the ability to think about
those people that you really want to
serve when you're scared and have no
idea how you're going to pull it off
but you chose to believe that you could
do it
you chose to believe that and because
you chose to believe
that you were able to achieve excellence
start from nothing stop for nothing what
does that mean
well i didn't come from a whole lot but
one of the things i've seen in my life
and that's one of the things i admired
just why i asked you off camera
what are you doing now right you're
doing this and all these other things
you have going in your life
so i i started from really nothing in my
life
but i'm not going to stop for anything
and what i find that most people do
and the reason i won't stop is because
there's this incongruency between that
identity thing i said earlier
what i think i'm capable of and where i
am i've never felt like actually i know
i've not really accomplished a whole lot
yet i've not
really arrived and the thing that i
think is the saddest in life is when
people don't work on their identity and
all of a sudden their results do catch
what they think they're worth that's a
formula for death because you're only
growing or dying in life
once you start to exceed or catch what
you think you're capable of
you stop growing and you stop and that's
when things get real
dangerous in life it's like an athlete
that retires it doesn't find the next
thing all of a sudden
these guys are running around the gym
every day they got nothing to do
idle time and they start
self-destructing it's every career it's
not just athletes
and so what that means for me is my
motto is i want to always be improving
always be growing i always want to feel
like i haven't quite made it
that there's what i'm capable of and
where i am that incongruency is this
magnet that keeps pulling me forward
not to stop and i don't want to stop and
i'm like i'm loving doing this right
here right yeah
i could be sitting on the beach so could
you we could both be just doing nothing
which is what people
think they would do when they get to
that point
and some people do and they're miserable
they might enjoy it for a week or two or
six months
but the fact of the matter is you can't
live that way i want to always be not
stopping and growing
the fastest path for you to get to
success you're after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do
learn from them understand what they did
to get there and then
try on their hat right see what worked
for them and apply it to your business
this is what worked for me this is what
saved my company bill gates
saved my first company even though i've
never met him i haven't yet
we're gonna make it happen hopefully
hopefully hopefully soon
i was struggling i had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money
and i quit on my business partner and i
woke up the next day and said i need to
find a way to make this happen
like i can't quit on this too soon
because i'm going to regret it if i
don't keep going
and so i said who has done this before
who's done this and i thought of bill
gates which is the first person that
came to mind was bill gates so i looked
at his story and how did he
build microsoft was through partnerships
and so
i started making partnerships in my
business i had nothing else to lose i
was already at rock bottom right already
quit on my partner
it was hopeless so let's just give this
a shot
and within i don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner
i landed my first partnership deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars and at
the time guys i was making 300 bucks a
month so that money
meant the world to me like that was that
was bank and and more important than
that it it gave me hope you know like
this could happen this this business
could actually work
and it gave me a model to then go and do
it again and again and again and ever
since then
whenever i don't know what to do i'm
model success i find someone who's done
it
and i try to apply their strategies and
make it work for me
but this is the important thing not
every strategy is going to work the same
way
for them as it did for you so maybe
waking up early is your ticket maybe
waking up later
is going to be your ticket there's
people who've done both which is the one
that's going to work for you
you won't know by sitting on the couch
and thinking about it the best thing you
can do
is just go and try you try on their hat
right bill gates did this dan lok does
this bruce lee does this
awesome try it if you want to know the
seven things rich people do that poor
people don't
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there i feel fear quite
strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly 40 of all jobs
they project in the next 10 years